hello my name's Anthony lik and I'm
gonna be talking to you about a new
product that I've been working on over
the last couple of years which is the
cloud connector for Excel I'm going to
show you how you can use it to your
advantage so the first thing that I need
to explain to you is what is the cloud
connector for Excel well it's a plugin
for Excel which allows you to cool api's
through API function now if you've
watched Chad's talk he explains to you
what API function form function is
there's plenty of tutorials out there to
show you how to construct these and I'll
give you a brief recap on on what API
function is in a moment it basically
allows you to call work from api's from
within Excel which is pretty useful now
the other thing that we have added here
is the ability to call any Wolfram
language function from within Excel as
well which without the need to use a to
construct ap is now currently the
product only works with the Wolfram
enterprise private cloud but I've been
working hard in getting it to work in
the Wolfram cloud now in fact it does
work on the Wolfram cloud now but there
are a few things that are undesirable
security issues with the Wolfram cloud
so it's not recommended that you use
this product in autumn with the wulfing
cloud now but soon it will be ready to
do so so why would you want to use this
product you know why would you why would
you want to use a product for excel well
we're extending excels capability so
excel is good at a number of things the
the user interface is extremely good for
non-technical people even technical
people find it sometimes a lot better to
use than mathematical example having
that like two-dimensional interface can
be can be extremely beneficial so we
extend this by allowing
new functions to be written essentially
within Excel for Excel and these are
constructed from Wolfram api's and you
deploy them and then you can access them
with Excel I'll show you what I mean in
a moment it basically because we're just
extending excels capabilities it allows
you to use your already defined
workflows within Excel and just well
essentially extend them just adds to the
workforce it doesn't disrupt your
workflow and this is the most important
part is that the language that is used
within the cloud connector for Excel for
the functions that you create the end
user when we say end user we mean the
Excel user will be able to understand
what's going on without having to know
Wolfram language and the good news about
this as well is that the computations
are done server-side so you can have
advanced computations running within
Excel as people have you know their own
machines which aren't very powerful and
they want to do a more high powered
computation they'll be able to do so
with this product so let me give you a
recap of an API call in Wolfram language
so here we have a function API function
you can instruct it with the arguments
we've got arguments X there's only one
argument X which is an integer and it
just does X factorial so if I run this
it just returns to me the function you
know with any of the evaluated parts and
there aren't any evaluator parts here
and we've wanted to test the API we can
give an association in this case X is 10
and what we should see is a calculation
which gives 10 factorial which is which
is the result here so this is a little
great but this is just you know using
Wolfram language in the Wolfram language
setting in this case its Mathematica
so how do we get cool this in Excel well
first of all we can just see what a well
we've already seen what the API function
looks like and what we could do with
this API is we could run cloud deploy
API if we were to run this and we could
access this we can click on this link
and it would take us to the API me we
could call that API but we're not gonna
do that now we want to just access this
API within Excel now the only thing
that's different between a between yet
for the API functions and Rumble in
Excel is this parameter here which is
allowed cloud extra parameters goes to
war so if you have that to the end
everything else remains exactly the same
as the above and we can run this and
then we can deploy it now all I've given
it is a name name is useful it's much
better than having an anonymous API
because what we have here is an
anonymous API problem with that is it
becomes very difficult to to find I'll a
today if I give it a name factorial and
I run this what we'll have is my name
which what my username which was a Zed
and the and the name of the API which in
this case is is factorial now you can
extend this and you could say something
like API slash factorial if you want to
be more specific so it lives in the
folder API we will leave it like that so
you can see now let's have a look at
things in Excel we've got our Wolfram
[Music]
plug-in installed I'm already signed in
and what we should be able to do now is
run this API now we go equals Wolfram
API and then we said it was API slash
factorial and we had a parameter X and I
could say x equals 5 and we can see that
5 factorial is 120 now if I wanted to a
reference to cell I could do that very
easily as well I could say X 10 and then
just replace this 5 with c9
and run this as well and it will give us
10 factorial this is really cool so this
is the simplest example that I can show
you really of running an API with a
Wolfram API within Excel so let me show
you some more advanced API causes this
is where things you know you can start
to make like applications and things and
start to get things a bit more
interesting the first thing I want to
show you is shortest tour so the
shortest tour function is is really
simple you know we have a function
called find shortest tour and it can
take you know a list of entities a list
of geo positions or something like that
and it will it will give you a tour or
even you can even use it for a lot of a
lot of just basic generic graphs it
didn't even rely on geo positions to
work but anyway we're in this case what
we're doing is we are taking a country
and then we are getting the top 20
largest cities within that country and
we can see by opening up this this
entity box that it takes our variable
country and takes the largest 20 cities
it does the find shortest tour of all
those all the velocities and then what
we're returning is a geo list plot of
that tour with a list of the of the
cities in order of which city you visit
first so this has already been pre run I
suppose I could run it again
it doesn't hurt do that I will just
overwrite my previous API and now I can
look at it within Excel so go into Excel
and I'll open my shortest tour and I've
already pre made this this little
demonstration so what it'll take you
know it tells me what it does and I've
highlighted this red box and I should be
able to put in a country like Italy for
example and it should fill out the
desired desired spaces so as you can see
our tour is
from from Rome to Rome and we go to all
these locations and you can see these
locations here and I could change this
to France or Germany and we would get
the tours of all of these places which
is really really cool that's taking a
little bit longer for some reason but
that's fine you see that an arab box
comes up there with no it was not in the
arab box but a box comes up there to
illustrate to you that your api has been
running for a certain period of time and
you can disable your api's cancel them
things like that so that you don't have
to wait for the evaluation to finish so
financial data is another thing that is
pretty popular use of Wolfram language I
mean what and this is one of the
benefits of the Wolfram language as a
whole not just financial data but data
we curate as much data as physically
possible and the reason why this is
useful is that not only you buying into
the language or buying into the data the
data that we have and to be able to
access it access that within native
Wolfram language so example now Chad
mentioned listen is and is in his talk
was was the interpreter and that's what
that's what these values are here these
are interpretive values in the API
function but we've got interpreter type
financial index and if I to give a
string Apple for example it will give me
the Apple entity the financial entity
see here it says financial and you know
in keeping you know we are a non-biased
company will do Google and you see it
gives alphabet class a and Microsoft
which will give Microsoft so
really cool so what we want to do is
want to create an API which does
something so with with financial index
so it's going to take three parameters
financial index Excel date and Excel
data index a start date in an end date
and what it's going to do is it's going
to do something similar that we had
before above which gives us a plot of
that financial the financial data in
this case it's the volume and it's going
to also give us give us that data so not
only do we have a plot we also funnel in
the data and the reason why this is
useful is because yes wolf mangage is
great for being able to create nice
visualizations but also we want the
flexibility to be able to use that data
within within Excel so I've just bottled
this all up into a single API and the
reason why we have to use Excel Day is
because Excel has a weird way of or and
you know non normal way of establishing
what a date is and that is the number of
days since the first of January 1900 or
something like that so anyway let's run
this it's in a Zed financial data and
now I'll go to one of my pre-made
workbooks and I can show you that that
example so I haven't filled anything in
here I've shown you the API I didn't
want to rewrite it all out but I've got
my my values and my start date could be
something like 2nd of May 2011 to the
2nd of June 2011 I don't like give too
much data and I'll just say yeah let's
do a pool seeing as we know that it
works that's great and what we have is
we have financial data parameter start
date is c7 and day c8 and index is c9 so
when I run this we should get
back some information so and this is you
know I'm not really I'm not hiding
anything behind the scenes the the
shortest tour thing had a small thing
hidden but nothing nothing too crazy so
what we have here is we have a graphical
object which is this graphic here these
two cells are essentially linked and
then we have our data here so the good
thing about this is that we could then
do this plot in Excel if we wanted to or
use this data to do something in Excel
finally I have an example which I won't
show any the code for because it's much
more complicated but it's just to
establish the kind of things that you
could do with this product so here we
have like a reporting right so it's got
some macros behind the scenes so this is
kind of playing you know we're playing
with a few things here so we're using
VBA to create a macro and the macro
cools a Wolfram API the Wolfram API is
going to take a list of stocks and an
email address and when we execute that
we're gonna get a report back and it's
not gonna be an Excel report so let me
just show you what I mean so I select my
data C and this is you know this VBA
well this this box here is is made in in
VBA
and I'm gonna send it to an email
address and I'm gonna use cloud
connector for excel at gmail.com which I
specifically set up for this talk I push
submit and what we should get is a email
back so information max on your report
will be sent to your email address
shortly now this is something I created
specifically you know as a response if
the API is successful then it will
return to me this string so you can
start to add your own error handling
things like that and the API is actually
pretty simple because all it does is it
calls a a report generator
with these these these stocks now what
we should be able to do is go into my
email and we can see that my report is
ready it's coming from my email address
and tonie's ed at Wolfram comm and I can
open this up and we can see that we've
got a portfolio which includes all of my
stocks and it's got some like bits of
interactivity here to show correlations
between between stocks we can see this
correlations between Amazon Accenture
Microsoft and the odd stocks
Xerox IBM unisys etc and we have
interactive graphs here lots of text you
know and the thing is is that we are now
extending the capabilities of Excel by
giving something that Excel wouldn't be
able to produce very easily but I
produced it essentially from within
Excel so this could be an extremely
powerful workflow for certain people and
if you by the way if you're interested
in seeing the code for this I'm more
than happy to send it to you to send you
the information and you just have to
email antes ed @ gmail.com not aunt I
said the GMAT alone and he said at
Wolfram calm okay so what we can do is
we can call general Wolfram language
within Excel so we can call any Wolfram
expression within Excel it's not as
smooth and clean my personal opinion as
using an API for the Excel user but if
you're a Mathematica user Wolfram
language user it becomes a lot easier to
be able to construct certain expressions
without the need to deploy api's so
yeah and it works the same as as as
Wolfram api's you know you can use
values from the spreadsheet so let me
show you what I mean
I'll open a new spreadsheet now I need
to change my account I need to go to
wealth our test cloud and when I go to
our test cloud I'll sign in and I can
save this here is the sign in sauna
dialog I told you I was signed in before
and you know it's nice it tells us some
signed in this is a great and now we
have the Wolfram functions so we're
gonna do something like I don't know
random integer and with random integer
we're gonna take a couple of parameters
so we can use the Wolfram function and
we can say random integer and this
parameter and this parameter and what it
does is it slots these parameters within
within that function so what we should
have is I use the square brackets there
I'll use a lever type so we've got five
values between zero and hundreds so I
could change this to 15 and reduce it to
one if I wanted to and we can see how
this changes now I may want to adjust
this so I may want to link api's
together so I'm not a PI's Wolfram
functions together and this and this can
be done very easily so if I wanted to do
now the Wolfram function which did a
matrix plot of these values then you
know I could select these values like
this we also have another function
called array reference and what array
reference stars as it takes a it takes
you like top left value of your of your
array and it will automatically expand
out the values you'll see what I mean
here so if I run this it should just
give us a matrix plot of all the values
you selected one value but it shows them
all and the reason
why this is really nice is now I can
change the size and it will dynamically
expand based on the size and I can
reduce it if I want to as well and you
can see how it updates so I'll just show
you briefly the world from toolbar
you've kind of already seen it it's it's
this bar here and it has a few values
buttons that you can click signing in is
obviously the most important about just
gives you a bit of information about the
product preferences is useful because it
tells you you know where you know
certain bits of information allows you
to test and and some other parameters
the insert API call button brings up a
dialog which allows you to give an API
name I think I've already got some okay
I don't have any saves so I should be
able to go to example add to update this
and what it does is it searches for an
API and it tells you the parameters they
exist so I can just show you this over
here you know I want our twelve to have
a add two or five and two and if I
insert here you can see that it does
Wolfram API of five and two and its
return seven there's a button to insert
four parts if you want to use files as a
as a parameter you can do recalculate
workbook again now just recalculate
everything because you may you may want
to do that for whatever reason if you've
got a non static result for an API so
rerunning it will change the result and
you know if you need to do work and you
don't want to call the call any Wolfram
API so you can disable them by clicking
this button so in conclusion what I've
hopefully showed you is that
a product which is designed around the
Excel user the Excel user is someone who
is non-technical and it will be able to
use api's that a developer has created
for their use now currently only works
at the enterprise private cloud but I'm
telling you very soon it will be made
available for the public cloud so it's
you know if you want to register your
interest go ahead Wolfer api's they
require very minor changes to work
within Excel I've told you that allowed
cloud extra parameters those two all is
the only thing that you need to change
what I didn't show you but it's very
simple is you know we've signed in so if
you're signed in what it means is that
you're able to control API access with
authentication there's something you can
go to to Chad's talk and read his notes
and he talked to you about assigning
permissions and things like that and
finally you know you're able to call any
Wolfram expression from within Excel
using the Wolfram function now if you
want to see some find out more here are
some resources you can go to the cloud
connector for Excel page for the
information on why you'd want to use the
product the resources page within that
within that site has a number of things
allows you to download the plugin allows
you to download an example spreadsheet
and a couple of them a couple of things
also allows you to access the
documentation and here's a link to the
documentation as well okay great well I
hope you enjoyed that thank you very
much for listening I look forward to
hearing any feedback thank you